هذه الايام بعثته الحج الى السعوديه
تمهيدا لموسم حجم استثنائي مبادر الطريق
مكه احدى المبادرات التي استفاد منها مئات
الالاف من الحجاج في عده دول اسلاميه شهد
المتروك مره اخرى تعود تعرفنا على
المبادره وعلى رحلتها التي انطلقت قبل سته
اعوام تقريبا
قبل سته اعوام وتحديدا في العام 2017
اطلقت وزاره الداخليه السعوديه مبادره
طريق مكه ضمن برنامج خدمه ضيوف الرحمن
التابعي لبرامج رؤيه السعوديه
2030 بهدفي رحله حج ميسره وبجوده عاليه
للحجاج المستفيدين بدات المبادره في دوله
واحده هي ماليزيا وتوسعت لتشمل الان ثمان
دول عربيه وافريقيه واسيويه احداثها تركيا
التي انضمت امس الى الدول المستفيده ووصلت
اولى رحلات الحجاج الاتراك الى مطار
المدينه المنوره ضمن المبادره المبادره
تعمل على انهاء اجراءات الضيوف الرحمن من
بلدانهم بدءا من اصدار التاشيره
الالكترونيه ونقلهم الى اقامتهم وانهاء
اجراءات الجوازات في مطار بلد المغادره
ونقلهم الى مقر اقامتهم في المشاعر
المقدسه عبر مسارات مخصصه واستفاد من
المبادره حتى الان اكثر من
376 الف حاج طوال الاعوام السابقه وزير
الخارجيه الماليزي وصف مبادره طريق مكه
بانها فكره ونهج ابداعي تنفذه السعوديه
لتسهيل رحله الحجاج معربا عن سعادته
باستفاده الحجاج الماليزيين من هذه
المبادره
في فيديوهاتنا من الرياض ينضم الينا
المهندس محمد ابو الخير اسماعيل الرئيس
التنفيذي لبرنامج خدمه ضيوف الرحمن مبادره
طريق مكه ايضا حياك الله معايا مهندس
اسماعيل حياكم الله اليوم المبادره تعود
بصوره مختلفه
ستعود ارقام الحجاج لوضعها الطبيعي ما قبل
الجائحه فبالتالي
كيف يتم التعامل الان من خلال هذه
المبادره مع هذه العوده بدايه اشكركم على
الاستضافه
واحب ارفع التهنئه الى القياده الرشيده
الحمد لله الاخبار الجميله تتوارى
تتوالى عفوا من استقبال الحجاج الى عوده
رواد الفضاء السعوديين بفضل الله وحمده
بسلامه الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وكذلك الاخبار الطيبه عندكم في القناه
قناه العربيه الجميله دائما الجوائز
فلا يسعني الا انك كذلك اني اوجه الثاني
لكم الله يعطيكم العافيه ما يخفى عليك اخي
خالد وعلى الساده المشاهدين بفضل الله
تعالى عادت اعداد الحجاج هذا العام الى
سابق عهدها الان مبادره طريق مكه تحقق
بفضل الله نجاح متتالي منذ اطلاقها
اليوم بامر الله تعالى نحقق ونطبق هذه
المبادره في سبع دول مختلفه ودولتين
اضافيه هي جمهوريه تركيا وكذلك جمهوريه
ساحل العاج اذا نظرنا الى هذه المبادره
دائما نعمل في منظومه الحج والعمره بتكادف
جميع الجهات ذات العلاقه في ان نحلل كل
مراحل رحله ضيف الرحمن ونسال نفسنا السؤال
المهم هل نحتاج الى هذا الاجراء اذا كنا
نحتاج هذا الاجراء كيف يمكن ان نطور هذا
الاجرام وهذا هو المقصد من وراء مبادره
طريق مكه التي حقيقه تتكاثر فيها بالنسبه
لي تعتبر مجال للابداع وكذلك مجال للتعاون
الكبير ما بين كل اصحاب المصلحه في هذه
المبادره واللي تزيد عن سبع جهات حكوميه
مختلفه تعمل بشكل متكاتف نعمل في هذه
المبادره على انهاء كافه الاجراءات منذ
بلد الضيف بحيث انه يصل ضيف الرحمن الحاج
الى المطار وينتقل مباشره من باب الطائره
الى باب الحافله الى
مقر سكنه ويجد كذلك
امتعه جاهزه في مقر السكن
توسع كبير وزياده في الاعداد عام بعد عام
وان شاء الله تعالى كذلك يكون مستقبلها
النجاح والتوسع
السؤال الحاج يمكن ما تغير لكن اليوم بعد
المبادره كيف تتعاملوا في الاجابه على
اسئلتهم الفائده اللي انا حاخذها من بعد
الانضمام او انضمام دولتي الى هذه
المبادره لاجراءات كيف ممكن تيسر او تسهل
وصولا الى الى اداء المناسك وعوده كذلك
الى بلاده بالنسبه لنا المعيار الاساسي في
هذا الموضوع هو تجربه الحاج ومستوى رضا
الحاج نعمل من خلال مع شركائنا في منظومه
خدمه ضيوف الرحمن على قياس مدى رضا الحجاج
عن هذه الامور وعن جميع مراحل تجربتهم منذ
ان ينتوا القدوم الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه سواء الاداء الحج والعمره وحتى
يعود سالمين عوده على النقطه اللي تفضلت
فيها تحديدا
الحاج يهم ان يؤدي نسكه وان يحصل على ارق
الخدمات وكذلك ان يتجاوز كافه الاجراءات
وفق افضل الممارسات العالميه وهذا ما تحقق
هذه المبادره لا يضطر الى الانتظار ابدا
بكل يسر وسهوله وتنتهي كافه اجراءاته من
بلده فيصل ويتجاوز كافه الاجراءات وينتقل
في ثلاثه شديده جدا فهي تعتبر اضافه عاليه
بالنسبه له اذا المعيار الفني هنا هو وقت
الانتظار الذي لا لا يحسب بحكم انه لا يقف
اصلا في مراحل القدوم في ست سنوات عندنا
بس سبع دول انضمت الى هذه المبادره من 57
دوله اسلاميه دوله واحده عربيه من 22 هي
عدد الدول العربيه لما تشوف ان وتيره
انضمام هذه الدول بطيئه او بطيئه جدا
يعني في خلال هذه الفتره مش المفروض مثلا
يوم نتكلم عنها كل شيء ثلاث كل سنه مثلا
نقول 18 20 دوله ولا انا مستعجل زياده عن
اللزوم صحيح لكن يجب ان نتذكر كذلك انه
العامل الماضي عاده اعداد الحجاج بما
يقارب كان عدد الحجاج فقط مليون حاج وكذلك
استمرت هذه المبادره و خدمت مجموعه من
الحجاج اذا ما كنت واهم خمسه دول خلال
العام الماضي
ويعني جائحه كورونا لا اعادها الله
توقف قدوم الحجاج من خارج المملكه على مدى
سنتين
بشكل دقيق نقدر نقول انه هذه ممكن تكون
رابع سنه لهذه المبادره وزياده جيده وكذلك
احب اركز كذلك على الدول الموجوده ذات
كثافات سكانيه كبيره وتخدم اعداد كبيره من
الحجاج فالمساله كذلك تحتاج اننا ننظر لها
من جوانب مختلفه من ناحيه
وطلبات من دول للانضمام بطبيعه الحال
كل كل دوله تسعى الى توفير
الخدمات هذه الاضافيه الى حجاجها وكذلك
الزملاء حقيقه ان قاده هذه المبادره
زملائنا في وزاره الداخليه لا يتوانى عن
تقديم هذه الخدمات ابدا للجميع
واحب حقيقه هنا اكرس او اركز على الشكر
كافه الجهات التي تعمل في هذه المنظومه
بقياده وزاره الداخليه ان كان وزاره الصحه
ولا اريد ان اذكر الجهات سواء كان وزاره
الصحه او وزاره الحج والعمره هيئه
البيانات الطيران المدني الزكاه والضريبه
والجميع حقيقه انا كنت ما بدي اذكر بعض
الجهات حتى لا انسى البعض لانه الحمد لله
عمل تكاملي جميل يعكس انصهار كافه جهات
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مع المبادره هذه تقلت في وضعها ولا زادت
ولا كيف بالنسبه
خليني اقول هنا انه هي تتعلق بتيسير
الاجراءات اكثر ولكن دائما ما تضمن
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وصول الحجاج
تكاليف
متوفره لدى الجميع وتقدم لهم افضل الخدمات
على كافه مراحل الرحله انا اشكرك جزيل
الشكر جزيل تمنياتنا لكم بالتوفيق شكرا
جزيلا لك دائما تتواجد معنا مهندس محمد
ابو الخير اسماعيل الرئيس التنفيذي
لبرنامج خدمه شكرا لكم شكرا لكم على
الاستضافه وشكرا الله يحييك
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات